[Music]  you won't believe what i found  what is this  seeds  yeah we are so like you and i vespa  because we won't let this world crushes  but don't think that you can change the  order of things  i have skills  i taught myself  the citadel likes control  could open its doors to everyone there  wouldn't be enough resources  but they left us nothing  i need to find a key to unlock the seeds  i'll make them fertile so we never  starve again  i'm camellia  vespa  she's not our responsibility she's from  sister she's taking us there let's go  pilgrims  drifters  bandits  [Music]  you have to be really careful who you  trust  the citadel will be ruthless  that can't stop me  perspire  you can change everything  [Music]  you